[Música]
lo más importante en la escuela
español
matemáticas
ciencias
sí mismo
artes o deportes
piensa en un momento y díganme qué es lo
más importante en la escuela
me dicen si cambiaré porque no estoy
viendo cambio
no está cambiando
ok ya vi ya cambio apareció la foto de
alguien famoso ok
esa persona que es mahatma gandhi decía
que a los niños antes de enseñarles a
leer debemos ayudarles a que
aprendan lo que es el amor y la verdad
yo de niño nunca fui bueno para la
escuela
tengo que confesar que cuando estaba en
primaria o en secundaria me la pasaba en
el departamento de orientación a veces
hasta en dirección en segundo de
secundaria ya me iban a correr
porque porque no me gustaba la idea de
pasar tantas horas frente a los libros
de texto
muchas veces me sentía tan confundido
con lo que me pedían mis maestros
y esa confusión generaba conflicto
pero
ahora que hice porque no sé
cómo
esa pregunta es bien importante les
damos el suficiente tiempo a los niños
para que sean niños les voy a platicar
una historia
cuando yo era pequeño 67 años 8
lo que me gustaba era estar con mis
amigos
jugar pero sobre todo imaginar imaginar
me encantaba era algo que para mí era lo
máximo
les cuenta otra cosa yo quería ser
paleontólogo de niño y tenía muchísimos
dinosaurios ahorita les voy a presentar
a dos
este si lo alcanzan a ver está chiquito
y se llama el huesos porque será pues
porque está lleno de huesos
lo curioso es que la imaginación de niño
me daba tanto que hasta tenían
personalidad les voy a presentar a lulú
ella es lulu es servidora aunque tiene
dientes aquí
y como es mujer tiene muy buen carácter
como todas las mujeres de aquí nada más
que a veces la luz
pierde la cabeza
cuando yo llego a ser maestro empieza
una educación primaria
lo curioso es que los niños de primaria
quieren jugar quieren reír se quieren
pararse ya mí ya se me había olvidado
todo eso se me había olvidado que de
niño me encantaba jugar e imaginarme
cosas
tuve que reinventarme porque por lo
siguiente a ver si cambia el cambio si
él es un comediante inglés
que dice que si queremos trabajadores
creativos debemos de darles el tiempo
suficiente para que jueguen sí
entonces cuando yo llego primaria y
tengo todos estos conflictos con los
alumnos que quieren jugar que quieren
estar parados que quieren divertirse
me tuve que sentar tuve que reflexionar
y tuve que darme cuenta que me tenía que
reinventar como maestro en ese
reinventarme
conseguí una metodología muy innovadora
no cambio perdone es disculpen
ahora sí que padre es bonito verdad
con seguir una metodología que contempla
cuatro aspectos super importantes del
desarrollo humano psicología sociología
marketing que es algo muy nuevo
y pedagogía
y la metodología se llama gamificación
qué es lo que les vengo a contar el día
de hoy cómo se implementa para qué es
cómo la puedes utilizar comenzando con
tres sencillas cosas con las que empecé
yo como maestro la primera de ellas
campeón o cambio
ahora sí verdad se vio un tablet grito
ahí al fondo
sí sí estoy en lo correcto ok les voy a
enseñar este tablero
ese tablero que ya nada más me queda una
parte
lo hice con hojas recicladas bueno era
carpetas más bien
para que es este primer elemento de la
gamificación
lo principal es que el alumno esté
consciente de que tú como maestro estás
comprometido con ese juego educativo que
te tomas el tiempo de hacer las cosas y
sobre todo que es importante para ti que
jueguen
en ese tablero que pueden ver ustedes en
la pantalla los niños hacían un registro
de avances dependiendo de las
actividades que tú quisieras asignar la
primera de ellas o
si cambia o si no
ya ok
la primera de las cosas cómo podían
ganar puntos en ese tablero era el
trabajo en equipo
pero ojo tenían que ser equipos bien
integrados
tienes que contemplar que hay por lo
menos una persona buena de cada área de
las materias que estás asignando o de
los temas que estés viendo en este caso
de la foto vemos a una persona muy buena
de mate de español de ciencias y de
artes
cuando se ponen las dinámicas de equipo
la persona de matemáticas
en su manera de entender las cosas de
comprender las ayuda a su compañero de
equipo a que él también las entienda que
las aplique y que las practique
caso curioso en específico s la persona
que era buenísima para matemáticas era
muy mala para artes
pero la personita que era buena para
artes era muy mal en matemáticas
entonces esos equipos se complementan se
hacen fuertes porque porque tienen ese
objetivo de como equipo ganar juntos
hacer el trabajo juntos y siempre salir
adelante
juntos
pero también existía la otra posibilidad
de hacer puntos de otra manera de una
manera individual
con esta super caja forrada brillosa si
la alcanzan a ver todos esta caja no me
costó mucho 20 o 30 pesos la caja de
zapatos ya la tenía obviamente nada más
fue la forrada
pero para ellos era maravilloso tener la
posibilidad de sacar una de estas
hojitas de color
y hacer un ejercicio que le abonará
puntos a su equipo no dejaban de ser
ejercicios de ciencias de español de
artes pero el hecho de que estuvieran
ahí adentro de que fueran hojas de color
y de que pudiera ganar puntos para su
equipo y ser parte importante de él
era lo que lo hacía fuerte a la
actividad
qué es la
la parte importante de la gamificación
que al final de todos los vas a
bonificar
a la semana al mes al día si tú quieres
y los puedes bonificar
con lo que tú desees ejemplos hicieron
los ejercicios de español súper bien en
la parte de equipos cada uno entregó
cinco o seis hojas de ejercicios extra
de su caja maravillosa
el tema de español de la semana ya lo
vieron lo dominaron lo entendieron como
equipo y lo entendieron individual
oigan chicos de premio el sábado y el
domingo no van a hacer la tarea de
español para ti como maestro es bueno
pues no hacen la tarea saben cuál es la
emoción de ellos
no vamos a hacer la tarea de español
guau qué padre ganamos equipo vamos a
seguirle echando ganas siempre todos
todos y la semana que entra nos vamos a
esforzar el doble para volver a ganar
porque somos un buen equipo y porque
todos podemos
y llegué a primaria y me di cuenta de
que los niños son creativos por
naturaleza que son juguetones que
siempre quieren lo mejor en la escuela
yo como adulto me había vuelto
sistemático
metodológico monótono
pero la escuela siempre requiere
maestros creativos para alumnos
creativos ahí le voy a cambiar
yo tuve que ver
y usar muchísimos ángulos en ese reto de
primaria para darme cuenta de que los
alumnos tenían que disfrutar la escuela
tenían que sentirse cómodos tenían que
estar bien emocionalmente dentro del
salón de clases para que todos lo demás
se dieran por qué porque si no estaban
cómodos y no sentían el espacio a gusto
si no se sentían bien no iban a tener
ningún contenido no iba a tener ninguna
trascendencia lo que hiciera la vi la
educación de varios ángulos y estoy
seguro
en todas las escuelas
puede y debe estar un maestro que les
ayude a disfrutar
lo interesante de esta situación es que
tengo alumnos y exalumnos
que quieren continuar el diálogo conmigo
que quieren seguir teniendo esta
relación y muchos me dicen que quieren
participar otra vez de nuevo en una
clase mía
porque me fui construyendo esa idea de
que efectivamente la educación si
obviamente siempre va a necesitar el
juego en el aula siempre debe estar
presente el juego y cosa curiosa a
muchos de nosotros como maestros y como
alumnos nos han dicho la escuela no es
para jugar disculpame aquí se viene a
estudiar
bueno y tú como le enseñaste a tus hijos
los colores
con un juego como le enseñaste a tus
hijos oa tus alumnos los números jugando
y ahí viene el ejemplo que me gusta más
cómo enseñar a los niños a decir papá y
mamá los cargas de mi papá y papá la
gaita el niño con todo al lado hábitat
no
y con balbuceos y con juegos sacas sus
primeras palabras que son para ti
importantes
entonces porque queremos eliminar el
juego del aula
y no nos cuesta nada no es llenar las
escuelas
de computadoras de ipads de tablets
tenemos el recurso más importante que es
la imaginación de los niños
como último me gustaría comentarles y
compartirles esta frase de un humanista
y filósofo francés
los juegos infantiles no son tales
juegos sino sus más serias actividades
gracias
[Aplausos]